sì dài dài dietro di te ti togli i miei
capelli e non ti cambi mai vestiti ci è
costato solo una settimana ragazzi
allora c'è un problema di fondo chi vive
da solo
ok non fa mai un cazzo di quello che ti
fa fare la mamma quindi c'è la casa che
un casino ho letto che è disfatto e non
lo state vedendo grazie a dio cioè la
pattumiera sparsa per la cucina non mi
vesto e non mi taglio i capelli non
cagate mi pene non siete mia madre bella
lì dopo questa premessa poi li c'e nei
suoi video grazie ed altro so che mi
vedeva fare incazzare stare ovunque è
piaciuto tantissimo altro episodio di
tappeto e quindi dai che sono carico
come lo schifo vabbè ragazzi se lontani
succhia aperto dove eravamo rimasti
l'ultima volta mi pare che fosse questo
non vorrei dire una cagata
va bene che bello vedevo l'ora giuro
piano non mi ricordo a confidarsi un
attimo un attimo succhiato haga con cui
quello di questo gioco secondo me è la e
l'inferno io non ho mai visto nella
bomba berluti come come lo dovrei
schivare spiegano come l'odore stivali
melo lo sta facendo
papà
[Musica]
ero a metà e metà marzo la madre zoppa
bifolca poi diventa gigantesco e fa la
stessa porca vacca schifosa nicola e ci
mette un'ora e mezzo come lo schifo lo
vedi che ti muore la sorella di epatite
come baggio a schivare un pugno che vale
metà schermo con noi non posso passar lì
sopra perché non si può non posso
passare sotto posso fare niente no la
gara cioè non sarebbero così non ci
avevano mai più piccolo dico e morto don
è morto non è morto è morto non è mondo
non è morto è morto per forza fatta col
tamura quanto la ragazza ben quanto dura
un abbraccio farò mai più si è calato
uno schiavo o chi ha occhi orario anche
no no
quanto toolan boscosi un'ora e mezza di
komos alla gara è incredibile misura sta
durando una vita
[Musica]
è vero
come se scassato joystick dai ragazzi un
altro joystiq che cosa abituati si vabbè
però ci sono ricordando di averne un
altro gli riserva e cassetto nuovo
grazie ad ios è uno di quegli scali di
col cavo sempre proprio già qualcosa
bene perché mi colpisce come dire perché
ciò solo qui sotto il suo pistoia
ufficio solo di questo perché arrivo
sempre alla fine cristo
ragazzi vi rendete vi rendete conto di
quanto è difficile questa roba
se vi rendete conto di quanto c'è un
nome non vi rendete conto perché
dettaglio però porca vacca laida c'è
veramente da ccc tua sorella ceva via
basta non voglio più vedere starace 21
ma proprio guarda lascia perdere cosa da
fare
area plan blueprint bisogna dire sud
specie a c'è qualcosa su un aereo a che
figata lo spero non sia un boxer è un
boss sempre proprio maestro gioco a ci
sono solo bossi sto gioco quindi
arrivato avevo tutto su un aeroplanino
ao affacciano gas
quindi la presunzione che non arrivano
neanche a mentali vento prof
va beh lui livello facile insomma è
difficile ma secondo me potrebbe essere
fattibile secondo poi magari non è così
mio dio oh mio dio aiuto cosa dovrebbe
rappresentare una vita da un'ora e mezza
tra l'altro non opera l'ho detto era che
l'ho detto attenzione ma vuoi durare
qualcosa come 6 ore come posso mica è un
ora che mi sto imparando quanto dura
questo post vi giro onorari sta andando
avanti basta dalla cimentino l'ho
battuto non andremo raffigurate ma
[Musica]
secondo me devo aver paura però non è
detto
ora che ho una vita da sei ore ed è per
forza vita era uno rachele sistema aveva
una vita più o meno dalla prima sti
cella praticamente c'è incredibile lo sa
neanche come ho fatto
ma cos'è che dovrebbe rappresentarli
cappuccetto rosso sul monociclo che
questa roba anche all'arcadis americani
bruxelles ma non c'era prima questo ma
cos'è aiuto ma è capito ma come non
c'era prima quindi sono random le
trasformazioni che associa la
trasformazione finale in luna di strà
minchia
[Musica]
forte concentrazione e ragala fine
concentrazione che ho tutte e tre le
vite ancora perfetta 12 perfetta né una
[Musica]
madonna cosa schivato potresti morire
per cortesia hack knock out lockout
[Musica]
se fossi qua da solo e non davanti alla
webcam e quindi davanti ai 4 milioni di
profondi io vi giuro il monitore era già
per terra ma dei bossi sembra quasi un
gioco per bambini perché se non ti
facesse salire il crimine ma non i
paesaggi distruggere gli ufo vabbè
ragazzi incredibile categoricamente di
giocare a questo scrivono non ce la
posso fare lo giuro che spa qualcosa se
non ebbe lo giuro scoma basta tanto
l'inizio cosa cosa continua così tanto è
che vorrei aprire la barra di gioco 9 di
aprile tua madre tua madre come rischio
i dischi volanti come di schivo come ti
scrivo i dischi come come li scrivo
aiuto aiuto come vi scrivo con rischi va
va va
1 a a [ __ ] a [ __ ] 1 a dire
157 l'ultimo tentativo in totale un'ora
e 57 di meno la mamma sativa il gioco
può essere difficile però dai così
veramente troppo se non assente da
quanto ho capito sono tutti i boss non
ho fatto mai un livello normale tranne
il primo ma credo fosse il tutorial a
questo punto l'anno in gran è come non
detto adesso che sta vivono normale lo
sapevo è variabili ci sono anche livelli
normali martin sono molti più bossi che
livelli normali quindi se i giorni giro
sono talmente abituato a stare fermo per
mettere i boschi non vi dico non ci si
muove madonna cosa schivato cosa schio
aiuto costo schivando cosa ho schivato
in tutto questo un casino fatto aiuto
ecco mano scrive niente sparkle demonia
porco porco ho preso non morire non
morire che aiuta le monete o tutte le
monete praticamente non devo morire mai
[Musica]
no no no no non era il finale mancano
ancora un'ora e mezza pro
[Musica]
si no
io sta parte qua prima lo schivata per
miracolo
se non potete veramente pensare che ogni
volta mi vada di culo così no no no no
ragazzi ragazzi veramente non ci stiamo
capendo per i giovani no no
madonna di madonna madonna demonio cosa
mi ha colpito cosa non c'era niente lì
sotto non c'era niente che mi ha colpito
non ha colpito nulla cosa ma siete
stupidi
no no no no no [ __ ] e non metto neanche
l'altro po così
[Musica]